mon sens nous sommes le jeudi 10
décembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour votre actualité locale
accompagnés de nos invités mais aussi
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite les titres de cette édition les
jouets que les enfants attendent au pied
du sapin nous verrons les tendances de
cette année chez la reine des neiges et
star wars devrait être sans trop
surprise en tête des ventes dans les
magasins de jouets et noël c'est avant
tout l'occasion d'exprimer sa solidarité
au château de versailles vient de se
tenir l'opération tous en fête avec la
croix rouge
nous reviendrons sur cet événement et
puis ans ford focus sur la prochaine
saison des cougars l'équipe de baseball
de montigny le bretonneux recrute pour
son équipe seniors nous en parlerons
dans la chronique
enfin si vous êtes un habitué de la
ligne n qui relie notamment rambouillet
à paris montparnasse vous avez peut-être
rencontré des difficultés depuis lundi
ces difficultés sont liées à un
mouvement social des conducteurs de la
ligne les grévistes sont en désaccord
avec le changement de service prévues
par la direction pour l'année 2016 une
réorganisation qui prévoit la mise en
service de nouvelles rames sur la région
de paris montparnasse nécessitant une
intensification des journées de travail
des conducteurs
axel perd son délégué cgt de versailles
et conducteurs de la ligne
elle s'est exprimée sur ce sujet on
écoute le service la nuit va être
intensifiée on va dire alors plus de
trains par contre la direction mais plus
de 30 circulation mais pour park depuis
deux conducteurs donc ça veut dire que
pour assurer une charge de travail
supplémentaire avec le même donc deux
conducteurs chaque conducteur doit
conduire plus de trac avant raphaël
gamme
alors oui c'est une dégradation évidente
que le point de son travail qui n'est
pas en suisse 8 sans causer problème
évidemment sur la capacité à être
vigilants sur la ligne d'autant plus que
en interne mais connaît pour être
particulièrement accidentogène en raison
justement du rythme de travail qui
étaient là à s'élever sur cette ligne et
le mouvement social a été reconduit
jusqu'à demain minimum des perturbations
sont à prévoir il faudra donc
s'organiser
j - 14 6 les lettres au père noël ne
sont pas encore envoyé il va falloir se
dépêcher
alors quelles seront les jouets stars
qui remporteront le plus de succès cette
année
mélanie fait paul melly poker fait le
point sur les tendances nouvelles de
ce n'est pas vraiment une surprise cette
année les cadeaux les plus prisés ce
seront les produits dérivés des licences
entendez inspiré des films et séries à
succès je pense qu'elle aime bien arcade
et violeta épouse yoko barricades pour f
tout ce qui est nouveau tout ce qui sort
en lego star wars
j'en ai un plus petit qui demandent
plutôt des autocollants ou des petits
personnages pelvienne parce que
l'actualité est tout trouvé c'est star
wars qui devrait rafler la mise des
jouets qui attire les petits mais aussi
les grands enfants
la tendance 2015 star wars
l'incontournable monde magique et
stratégiques start oise dans le film
sortira le 16 décembre dont star wars
vous allez retrouver les produits sous
différents différents dérivés vous avez
aussi des talkie walkie vous avez des
patinettes vous avez tout ce qui est
chaude pour soupçon et depuis deux ans
celle qui continue à être demandée par
les petits français c'est elle
elle a accompagné de sa soeur anna se
décline cette année encore sous toutes
les formes
atelier de création coffret poupées et
bien d'autres encore en 2014 les
français avaient prévu un budget moyen
de 300 euros pour leurs cadeaux de quoi
offrir des jeux vidéos et jeux
connectées encore de la partie pour 2015
et parce que les plus jeunes recopie
souvent les plus grands la mode us elvis
s'invitent cette année pour noël et les
plus petits ne seront pas oubliés
peluches et jouets favorisant l'éveil
seront sans doute très présents au pied
du sapin de quoi donner beaucoup de
travail au père noël et ceux les arrêter
à présent avec le secours populaire
français qui a lancé son opération père
noël vert comme chaque année toute la
journée d'hier l'antenne de la verrière
était à la maison de quartier du bois de
l'étang pour proposer jouets et
vêtements donnés par plusieurs grands
magasins
l'objectif de l'opération revendre ses
jouets à des prix cassés afin de
collecter des fonds qui permettront de
financer des activités pour les
bénéficiaires du secours populaire
écoutez nous collectons déjouer toute
l'année nous les trions nous récupérons
aussi des jouets neufs dans les magasins
certains magasins c'est ouvert à tout le
monde
il ya aussi d'autres personnes qui ont
des moyens plus limités qui ne viennent
pas dans nos antennes entre comme
bénéficiaire mais qui ont besoin aussi
de profiter de ces cadeaux à petits prix
la récolte de fonds permet au secours
populaire de d'intervenir dans les
vacances c'est pour elle au fait le
secours populaire a ramassé un petit peu
d'argent et nous ça nous fait profiter
aussi d'acheter des jouets pour noël
pour les enfants est à noter que 800
euros on peut être ont pu être récoltés
avec plus de 400 jouets vendus une
nouvelle vente sera organisée lundi à
l'antenne du secours populaire de la
verrière avec les jouets restants et
justement pour vivre noël un peu avant
l'heure le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines organise ce week-end
un week-end spécial noël pour nous en
parler avec nous ce soir juliette dé
vous en charge des événements culturels
bonsoir à vous alors c'est la deuxième
édition cette année donc 2
duel qui se passait au vélodrome alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'est ce
qu'on va voir il paraît que le père noël
vient justement aussi oui le père noël
sera là aussi
donc ce qu'on propose cette année au
grand public de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est un événement très familial en fait
on a on va installer sur leur central de
nombreuses activités pour les enfants
pour les 3-14 ans donc c'est des
structures gonflables
c'est du baby foot humain c'est du laser
games et des ateliers créatifs donc on
va apprendre aux enfants comment
fabriquer des des boules de noël par
exemple c'est des activités autour de la
piste pour permettre aux plus petits
aussi de faire du vélo sur notre piste
activités autour du village vraiment
donc ça c'est la draisienne on propose
aussi un goûter de noël donc des crêpes
des béliers et c'est la 13e c'est une
sorte de vélo oui c'est un tout petit
vélo pour que les enfants apprennent en
fait il ya eu pas mal d'événements
autour de la danse a donc à ce week-end
oui on a mieux on a souhaité mettre en
lumière la danse et les associations du
territoire
donc les 3b nouvelle génération vous
venir faire une démonstration de hip hop
on aura aussi un présentateur que de la
chaîne gulli qui viendra faire une
chorégraphie pour les enfants et enfin
on a de la zumba pour pareil pour les
enfants ou baky de grâce est destiné à
tous les enfants qui habitent au décès
certain âge qui sont ciblés on cible
principalement les 3 12 ans mais comme
je le répète c'est un événement familial
donc les parents aussi pourront s'amuser
avec leurs enfants à travers la seconde
bas à travers le baby foot géant laser
game c'est vraiment participatif alors
ça commençait de keller a killer un
petit peu le programme ici on venir le
matin qu'il ya alors ces deux sessions
par après midi donc samedi et dimanche
c'est des sessions de deux heures trente
la première commence à 13 heures et la
seconde commence à 16h30
on peut s'inscrire en ligne via notre
site internet ou bien acheter les
billets sur place
alors c'est 15 euros pour les enfants ça
fait quand même une certaine somme si on
vient voilà avec des parents et des
enfants cela provient quand même à
santoro c'est un petit peu cher
peut-être pour ceux qui viennent
c'est pour ça oui qu'on a mis en place
des pass famille donc en fait ça revient
10 euros par personne pour vraiment
accéder à une multitude d'activités
un accord est si injuste en vous
attendez combien de personnes surtout
week-end on attend 500 personnes par
sion à peu près je pense que on peut
atteindre l'objectif d'accord et comment
vous avez fait pour faire venir le père
noël vous avez un petit secret j'ai un
petit secret que je garde que vous
gardez pour vous bien merci à beaucoup
je voulais tu as roanne oui bah le noël
au vélodrome c'est ce week-end ne ratez
pas à l'événement et qui va accueillir
justement le père noël c'est vraiment à
ne pas rater et pour que noël n'oublie
personne c'était le slogan qu'arborait
le château de versailles le versailles
hier qui accueillait la quatrième année
consécutive l'opération tous en fête
organisée par la croix rouge française
avec le soutien de la fondation
d'entreprise fdj cet événement a permis
à 200 bénéficiaires de la croix-rouge de
visiter le château de versailles avec un
parcours privilégié pour l'occasion au
programme goûter spectacle d'immersion
et visites guidées des grands
appartements pour un public qui
découvraient les lieux pour la première
fois un reportage signé william l alors
si tu vois le roi veut pour ses
spectateurs c'est une première
bénéficiaire de la croix rouge
l'opération tous en fête leur a permis
mercredi le visiter le château de
versailles une visite particulière
puisque immersive grâce aux quatre
comédiens d'improvisation qui
jalonnaient chaque étape de leur passage
les journées ciel
me disant tu raison très il doit faire
vivre un personnage donc fait ressentir
une époque et en même temps être
accessible au public
mais dans une grande qualité donc
accessible ça veut dire bien se faire
comprendre du public et dans un jeu
dynamique
donc c'était vraiment un travail
d'équilibriste
voilà qui doit aussi mettre en valeur
les lieux et les tableaux des tableaux
utilisé comme support narratif un
majordome un journaliste un chanteur
d'opéra et la fille de louis philippe
voilà les quatre personnages qui font
vivre au spectateur l'inauguration du
musée de l'histoire de france sur ces
journées là avec l'événement sienne à la
possibilité de mettre en place des
moyens un peu décalée de découvrir de
découvrir les lieux donc peut-être plus
accessible que une visite libre
aucune visite conférence donc là on a
quelque chose de décalé donc plus
accessibles donc en effet on leur donne
la possibilité de venir voir des choses
qu'ils n'auraient pas vu autrement
hésité dans le rôle des personnages et
qu' il était marrant et voilà il était
bien ils ont bien fait lors leur père ça
leur travail leurs personnages et ils
ont bien présenter cette donne envie de
revenir
oui après le spectacle des jeux un
goûter et une visite des grands
appartements était organisé un événement
qui n'auraient pas pu voir le jour sans
la fondation d'entreprise française des
jeux et la croix rouge et qui a permis
l'espace d'une journée de faire briller
les
lire du château dans les yeux des
participants et nous allons à présent du
côté de trappes l'association trappe
action solidaire multiplie ses actions
je le rappelle l'association est née en
septembre 2015 elle regroupe aujourd'hui
une vingtaine de bénévoles a organisé ce
samedi 6 décembre un vide dressing dans
la salle gravaud attrape des articles
neufs ou en très bon état et est vendue
à une somme dérisoire pour aider les
familles les bénéfices de la vente vont
directement aux familles démunies aux
parents isolés dans le besoin et qui
habite trappe comme nous explique
mustapha ben la sem le président de
l'association
le but c'est en premier plan c'est de
d'avoir des fonds pour qu'on puisse
entamer la période hivernale comme il se
doit et aussi le but c'est devant des
vêtements de bonne qualité à un prix
défiant toute concurrence
c'est à dire un euro symbolique et nous
accueillons à présent notre deuxième
invité bonsoir à vous marque bastia et
merci d'être venu centre plateau vous
êtes le président de l'association pour
un revenu d'existence
alors l'association existe depuis plus
de 20 ans et une antenne vient de
justement de s'ouvrir dans les yvelines
à versailles
vous êtes donc un spécialiste de la
question car vous avez soutenu une thèse
de doctorat en économie justement sur le
revenu de base alors pourquoi parle-t-on
du revenu de base en ce moment car la
finlande envisage de mettre en place
donc ce dispositif c'est à dire 800
euros pour tous ses habitants en
remplacement de toutes les allocations
allouées et versée par l'état alors la
proposition finale ne sera pas présentée
par le gouvernement avant novembre 2016
même si c'était mais cette expérience
est menée à son terme le pays nordique
serait le premier à se lancer au niveau
national dans la rélève réalisation
effective de cette idée alors leur vie
bah c'est en somme voilà c'est une somme
pour tout le monde qui remplacerait tout
justement les allocations versées par
l'état
quel est alors le dessus il faut il faut
toujours se méfier un petit peu là la
simplicité c'est que il s'agit de fuites
de données à revenus identiques à toute
personne dans une communauté nationale
donc tous les adultes en général souvent
un montant différent pour les enfants et
dans cette démarche là effectivement on
est dans une démarche inconditionnels ça
que chacun a droit sur lui on le dit
souvent tout le monde soit les plus
riches paient plus pour certains mais
par contre la fiscalité une autre lui
différentes
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de revenu lui
paiera pas d'impôt quelqu'un qui a des
revenus élevés et une demande va coûter
beaucoup plus donc là donc la justice
fiscale et le point important mais
ensuite le fait que chacun ait de quoi
subsister
c'est cela qu'on va sur à tout le monde
là ce sont des actions c'est une idée
que personne ne connaisse pas pourtant
elle existe depuis très longtemps
le premier écrit que l'on connaisse au
dessus c'est 1795 thomas spain ça plus
de deux siècles mais néanmoins l'idée a
beaucoup évolué et s'est enrichie à
progresser et aujourd'hui qui vivent là
je suis pas qu'un petit bouquin un livre
que j'ai signé
au début de l'année l'ibère a remis en
liberté pour tous qui décrit comment
cela pourrait fonctionner en france
dirait en 2015
et évidemment ces dames mais qu'est ce
qui est fiscal et donc l'argent qu'on
les tribus sont distribués sous forme
d'un crédit d'impôt c'est à dire
distribuer à chacun sous forme fiscale
et la fiscalité assure justement la
redistribution le meilleur naturel alors
comment cela s'organise réussi voilà ce
revenu d exister arrivée en france
aujourd'hui concentration
déjà c'est une chose qui se substitue à
toute la complexité actuelle la première
complexité aujourd'hui c'est l'impôt sur
le revenu avec un feu survenu avec des
tranchées xixes d'exonération une des
quotient familial que son conjugale va
beaucoup de choses compliquées
l'idée ce courant passe ou ça donc on
line pour ça ensuite il y avait le rsa
le rsa qui effectivement est une
complicité également avec des
déclarations des démarches arv avaient
tous les trois mois et plus c'est
compliqué de l'appareil
la location pour les enfants aussi
l'accueil familial consorts famille à
tous ces mécanismes qui sont devenues
très compliquées au fil du temps qui
était au les personnes qui sont devenues
compliquées pareils on l'envoie en 1905
situation administrative
cette question majeure et surtout et
c'est comme plus important ce que pour
chaque citoyen je suis citoyen sait
exactement où il en est donc aujourd'hui
chacun peut faire le constat que ne sait
pas très bien ce que ce à quoi il a le
droit parce que c'est trop compliqué
donc il dépend de calcul avec des
mécanismes qu'on maîtrise pas bien et ça
c'était sur quoi nous nous positionnons
simplicité il ya un désherbage donc
c'est la simplicité forçant les indiens
l'argent aussi pour tourner il ya aussi
d'autres choses qui échangera un petit
peu la société dans sa totalité ont
notamment d'une action sur le chômage
également ans au chômage par l'idée
d'ailleurs jean tirole notre prix nobel
économie encore hier la radio qui disait
il faut arrêter de vouloir protéger
l'emploi il faut protéger les personnes
qui une fois que les personnes sont
gérés de bout avec les moyens de vivre
elles peuvent être activés et donc du
coup faire preuve d'initiative faire ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir s'insérer la
société de maintenir de manière à diré
digne alors qu'aujourd'hui on l'a
tellement de mécanismes variés que les
gens mais ils sont un petit peu
prisonnier de différence avoir été on
peut pas forcer les gens à prendre un
emploi plutôt les données ce qu'il faut
pour qu'il puisse l'être puisse choisir
de faire telle ou telle activité
c'est ça qui est pourtant le choix réel
des personnes la liberté réelle des
personnes
est ce que ce serait vraiment un vrai
moyen de faire des économies par exemple
pour les gouvernements à la question des
économies
bon on peut dire que les économies de
gestion effectivement s'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent pour être
ministre et que choses compliquées
forcément c'est pas efficace d'un point
de vue voilà bon ce n'est pas le sujet
majeur des quelques économies ok mais
c'est pas ce sujet majeur
l'idée c'est vraiment que les personnes
soient tout en position de pouvoir avoir
faire des choix réel de manière active
avec une vraie liberté c'est ça le sujet
majeur
ensuite selon montants sont choisis tout
le monde rendent extrêmement élevé
évidemment ça va coûter très cher comme
ça c'est pas viable si on fait un
montant très basse à pas être motivant
non ce n'est pas bon non plus alors même
qu'il faut juger le niveau qui a du sens
tel que l'on est telle que j'ai
travaillé là dessus
voilà ce niveau du rsa ceux qui ont
écrit là dessus de l'autre d'autres
moments d'autres endroits
joël bouquin sur sur un titre
intéressant d'un de l'actuel ministre de
l'éducation du québec qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions là et
quelques années voilà me font trembler
qui voilà qui parlera également à chaque
pays
il est une démarche à faire les
finlandais qui travaille sur les
questions ont commencé un processus de
réflexion ils ont commencé le 5 décembre
c'était la première réunion
ils vont tous les jours jusqu'au 15
novembre l'année prochaine il ya une
année de travail pour définir vraiment
les paramètres parce que malgré la
simplicité c'est en réalité très
compliqué de faire simple dans un pays
comme la france où comme la finlande
c'est la complexité qui fait que les
gouvernants sont attendus peu réticent à
cette idée à derval basse les gars ne
pas le gouvernement
son assistante beaucoup de politiques
nous rencontrons sont intéressés parce
qu'ils voient actuellement l'intérêt
d'avoir une vision claire d'avoir
quelque chose qui fait du sens qu'ils
adhèrent à sa part contre la mise en
place concrète
quand il s'agit de passer à l'acte le
premier frein sait qui sont les perdants
parce que des gens qui gagnent ça c'est
très bien à tout le monde est d'accord
pour qu'il gagne en mai les facs et
personnes qui éventuellement seraient
moins favorisés par le système actuel
cela pose une difficulté même si c'est
légitime
tu crois qu'il faut oser dire que
fois les personnes aujourd'hui pour les
raisons x ou y ont peut-être des
avantages qui sont peut-être un peu
disproportionné par rapport aux autres
est ce que ça existe et on ne sait pas
où ça va là ce sont des questions
difficiles pour les politiques c'est
forcément difficile
est-ce que voilà enfin l'on réfléchisse
à 7 à cette idée mais la flandre a
accueilli 6 1 millions d'habitants en
france on est dix fois plus
est ce que ce serait possible un tel
dispositif en france ce dispositif par
essence est applicable absolument
partout absolument partout il est étudié
en était étudiant en namibie il est
étudié aux états unis dit étudier au
canada au brésil au japon
c'est un sujet qui intéresse avant tout
le monde et tous les pays he a sa
manière de faire il faut pas croire que
c'est une solution qui va s'imposer mais
identique partout ce nom le concept
identique mais la déclinaison concrète
dans un pays demandent une étude
particulière qui ne peut se faire que
pays par pays et c'est vraiment à ça que
chacun travaille je suis partie d'un
réseau international qui s'appelle le
basic income ps network et donc nous
avons des promoteurs de cette idée dans
tous les pays qui tous travaillent sur
des solutions locales à leur pays et des
politiques en france qui porte cet hymne
est justement un des avantages à les
politiques il y en a de tous les côtés
des écologistes récemment ont voté en
faveur de cette poule 7
cette mesure quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien dans les yvelines qui cuisinent
boutin s'est engagé depuis longtemps sur
ce sujet là depuis plus de dix ans nous
avons également des personnes au niveau
du parti socialiste qui s'intéresse
également mais qui nous travaillons
actuellement
voilà donc séquelles c'est un sujet qui
vont transparence parti qui intéresse
tout le monde
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que nous avons
monté notre notre association locale du
mouvement français pour un revenu de
base dans les yvelines et tout récemment
justement pour essayer de faire venir
les personnes qui de quelles que soient
leurs tendances politiques aient envie
de partager sur ce concept là et dans ce
groupe très variés mais travailler
ensemble parce que justement nous
pensons nous pensons que un sujet comme
ça ne pourra avancer que par un intérêt
bien compris de tous les partis hier 9
décembre a été votée à l'assemblée il
mesure à l'unanimité droite et gauche
ont voté le même mesure qui est là
projet de loi de le rendre guilaume sur
territoire 0 chômeurs de longue durée
c'est une idée qui ne sont bien là sont
bien le fondateur de s'étaient déjà
rencontrés également de nos associations
donc et c'est un sujet qui est arrivé à
lui limité
le revenu de base lors d'une base comme
le rémi à 88 sera votée un jour on ne
sait pas quand à l'unanimité c'est
vraiment notre notre objectif est bien
merci beaucoup aux marques de baskets
venue sur le plateau nous avoir expliqué
tout sur le revenu de base
alors si vous voulez de plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet
www.manutd.com où il s'affiche en bas de
votre écran et le loca est à versailles
vous y retrouver toutes les informations
merci à vous fin et juste après les
attentats de paris du 13 novembre qui
vont coûter la vie à 130 personnes et
riz gras non un poète mort pas y en a
écrit un poème inspiré de l'émotion
ressentie lors des événements mise en
musique par le groupe chrysalis auquel
appartient et riz gras non le poème
s'adresse au président de la république
on regarde un extrait avons des côtés
justement l'artiste eric grall
monsieur le président
importe nous
je ne savais
on
parce qu'en ce nom
terminé
alors
le président
apportez moi
sous le coup de l'émotion je les écris
en dix minutes
ce poème et il est né comme ça le
président nous a répondu deux jours
après que je lui écris parce que je vais
envoyer le poème par écrit le 25
novembre et il m'a répondu le 27
novembre il était il m'a dit qu'il était
sensible à ma démarche
et comme chaque jeudi vous en avez
maintenant l'habitude c'est votre
rendez-vous la chronique sport avec
michael elle lui dérobant soir à michael
griesser florane aujourd'hui nous allons
parler baseball coup de projecteur sur
les cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
l'équipe senior a terminé son
championnat en septembre et alors
reprendre la compétition au mois d'avril
pour cette nouvelle saison les cougars
recrute pour nous parler du club nous
recevons sur ce plateau le coach de
l'équipe senior des cougars bonsoir
alors cette campagne de recrutement ça a
débuté à quel poste vous le vous
recruter cette saison alors le principal
poste ce sera le poste de lanceur c'est
le poste clé au baseball donc c'est ce
poste là qui nous intéresse et se sont
du coup des postes clés qui vous ont
peut-être manqué la saison dernière pour
postuler à une place en première
division pas forcément pas forcément
l'année dernière c'est pas c'est pas ce
poste là qu'on a eu des soucis avec
laquelle poste du coup plutôt au niveau
de la frappe
mais on va corriger ça cet hiver et donc
esquif qu'est ce qu'il faut pour pour
intégrer l'équipe est ce qu'il faut être
un joueur hors pair pour pour intégrer
l'équipe une sur la deuxième division
n'y a pas forcément besoin d'être un
joueur hors pair mais il faut avoir des
bonnes qualités athlétiques et sinon il
yad'autres d'autres équipes
l'équipe de jaloux également qu'on peut
intégrer alors y aller la jeune qu'on
essaie d'intégrer cette année c'est un
peu plus difficile
on se concentre plus sur des anciens et
quelle qualité du coup doit-on avoir
pour pour jouer au baseball
expliquez nous tous
déjà il faut avoir une bonne qualité
physique générale un bon bras est rapide
et être assez coordonnés mais s'est
donné à tout le monde se donne à tout le
monde connaît tout le monde et vous
intégrer les nouvelles recrues comment
quand vous les intégrer ces nouvelles
recrues a alors ça va dépendre si c'est
des joueurs on va faire jouer avec mon
équipe une
on va les intégrer directement dans la
première équipe
ou sinon on va les faire passer par les
équipes de ou équipes 3 et il ya des
stages qui sont organisés peut-être
avant pour créer une certaine cohésion
des kits si on va essayer de faire ça
cette année on s est créé à stains on va
essayer de faire un stage sur mars juste
avant la saison
voilà pour un petit peu à l'étranger ou
en france
en france en france et l'équipe l'équipe
se forme du coup entre 7 à la en fait
celle de décembre et la période d'avril
entre novembre et et marsouins et
l'objectif c'est pour essayer de créer
une cohésion des équipes ce qui est
primordial harvest volant non mais c'est
comme dans tous les sports collectifs il
faut vraiment justement créé cette
cohésion des clips pour arriver
justement au bout du championnat
il ya des joueurs des joueurs qui ont
déjà été recrutés cette saison on a huit
nouveaux joueurs
donc c'est plutôt pas mal ça j'en
prenais une oeuvre sur le terrain donc
on a
on a doublé tous les postes c'est
vraiment pas mal et je crois que vous
avez des étrangers qui nous on a un
italien qui nous a rejoint dominicains
et on recherche aussi un lanceur
américain et le club cette année le
visent on vise la remontée en première
division le titre de deuxième division
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
je rappelle des cougars de mon team moto
ne recrute cette saison après le
baseball maintenant parler du ballon
ovale le rugby-club de plaisir coachée
par jean miss jura ce week-end à
domicile pour prendre la 4e championnat
oui floral un match qui ne faudra
absolument pas rater pour plaisir le prc
reçoit ce dimanche à 15h maisons
laffitte au stade robert barran un derby
qui s'annonce électrique plaisir lutte
pour prendre la première place du
classement à ris orangis et de son côté
maisons laffitte lutte pour le maintien
vous l'aurez compris il devrait y avoir
du spectacle rendez vous samedi à 15
heures pour les soutenir
le rendez-vous est notée on termine à
cette chronique par du handball c'est
peut-être le match qu'il ne faudra pas
manquer pour le ch et néo promu cette
saison en nationale 2 les hommes coachés
par yannis norbert sont dans le dur ils
n'ont remporté qu'un seul de leurs huit
matchs disputés cette saison
conséquence les chaînes esi un pointe à
la dernière place du classement
le match de ce dimanche s'annonce donc
également compliquée pour les yvelinois
il affronte saint nazaire sixième du
classement les supporters devront faire
beaucoup de bruit dans les tribunes pour
les pousser à se transcender
voilà vous connaissez tous les rendez
vous sportifs du week-end dans le
département florent merci à michael
fectivement il va y avoir du sport ce
week-end on vous retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour votre taux question par les
sports voilà je brûle d'impatience et
doivent à quelques petites exclusivités
de quoi at-on parlé
nous avons parlé de golf avec la ryder
cup 2018 une compétition qui se
déroulera à saint quentin en yvelines
mais nous parlons également de handball
de l'équipe du chéné handball qui du
coup est dernière du classement alors ça
19h30 le programme a l'air à excitant
jeter le regarder merci à vous la
semaine prochaine on vous retrouve
également pour la chronique et demain
c'est une week-end c'est du fric sur
tous les fronts voilà je vais parler
cinéma avec bernard pinet mais je vais
également parlé musique il y en a tout
bien nous manquons pas de regarder merci
michael c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis donc quelques
instants donc à 19h30 si on parlait
sport le talk show présenté par michael
et demi d'euros entouré de
chroniqueur demain vous avez rendez vous
avec wilfrid errishi pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine
quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi je
vous souhaite donc une bonne soirée et
un excellent week end